just because you have switched one type
of obsession for another type of
obsession does not necessarily mean that
that obsession is more holistic You
could argue given the choice between
being obsessed with the gym and being
obsessed with taking that the gym is
objectively a better Obsession to have
but if you're going to get really down
to zero what we're talking about is how
can we sit with the discomfort of not
being enough how can we sit with the
discomfort of not having an obsession at
all what does that feel like the
externality could be like drastically
different for example like you could be
addicted or you could be addicted to
just like rampant entrepreneurial just
Financial just Hedonism in that young
due to how Society is it's celebrated
but like you said the most important
thing is realizing that fundamentally
you're a slave to an egotistical
construction with either one and the
goal is to transcend that even though
your egotistical construction that
you're feeding is societally rewarded so
that's a trap that you could really
really fall into so the key is you need
to go a little lower than that yep I
agree